Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It's the depths of the winter solstice. We're taking down the Saturnalia decorations. We've got Yule coming as well. And of course, it's Christmas. And we thought that here on The Rest Is History, we would give it a festive touch.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。冬至已至。我们正在收起农神节（Saturnalia）的装饰。圣诞节（Yule）也快到了。当然，还有圣诞节。我们觉得在《历史的余烬》节目里，也该增添一点节日气氛。
Did we not? Dominic Sandbrook, who is with me, Tom Holland. We did indeed. Dominic, are you in a festive mood? Do you like Christmas? Yeah, I love Christmas. Do you have, I mean, we have, so my son and I always watch The Box of Delights.
不是吗？与我同行的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），我是汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。确实如此。多米尼克，你现在有节日气氛吗？你喜欢圣诞节吗？是的，我太喜欢圣诞节了。我是说，我们有，所以我和我儿子总是看《奇幻盒》（The Box of Delights）。
Do you remember The Box of Delights? The 1980s BBC adaptation of John Maysfield's Christmassy novel. We watch that every year. God, that is, What a touching thought. My wife refuses to watch it, but we watch it. We've got Patrick Trout on it. Why does she refuse to watch it?
还记得《奇幻盒》吗？那是20世纪80年代BBC改编自约翰·梅斯菲尔德（John Masefield）的圣诞小说。我们每年都看。天哪，真是，多么感人的想法。我妻子拒绝看，但我们看。帕特里克·特劳顿（Patrick Troughton）还在里面演呢。她为什么拒绝看？
She says, you know, I've seen it once. It wasn't very good. I've seen no reason to waste my life watching it again. She's Christmassy that way. And then, obviously, on Christmas Day, because my son is nine,
她说，你知道的，我以前看过一遍。不是很好看。我觉得没必要浪费生命再看一遍。她对圣诞节就是这么冷淡。然后，很显然，在圣诞节那天，因为我儿子九岁了，
we spend the entire day arguing about making gigantic Lego models that he's received from Father Christmas. And basically what happens is my wife and I end up spending, you know, sort of three o'clock the next morning, we're still arguing about which is the lost piece and all this kind of carry on. So that's our Christmas tradition.
我们整天都在为搭圣诞老人送给他的巨大乐高模型而争吵。基本上情况就是，我和我妻子最后花时间，你知道的，大概到了第二天凌晨三点，我们还在争论哪块零件丢了之类的事情。所以这就是我们的圣诞传统。
But you still like Christmas? I love it. I love all that, yeah. It's that or talk to you. So, I mean, you know... Yeah, well love it. I love all that. Yeah. It's that or talk to you. So, I mean, you know. Yeah, well, when you put it like that. Let's crack on. What about you? You must have Christmas traditions.
但你还是喜欢圣诞节？我太喜欢了。我喜欢这一切，是的。要么这样，要么跟你聊天。所以，我是说，你知道的……是的，好吧，既然你这么说。我们言归正传吧。你呢？你肯定也有圣诞传统。
Didn't you have your turkey stolen out of the back of your car once? Am I right? Yeah, we did. Yeah, we did. We did. Well, we had a very small fridge. And so we couldn't fit the turkey in the fridge. So we thought we'll put it in the back boot of the car.
你不是有一次火鸡从车后备箱被人偷了吗？我没记错吧？是的，确实有。没错。好吧，我们家冰箱很小。所以我们放不下那只火鸡。于是我们想，把它放在汽车的后备箱里吧。
And some bastard came along and nicked it. So we had all the trimmings, but we didn't have turkey. Wow. That's a terrible story, isn't it? I just thought you'd love to share that with the public. Yeah, but I said that since then we've stopped eating dinosaurs. We have, of course. Birds are. But we do have the festive tradition.
结果哪个混蛋跑来给顺走了。所以我们配菜都有了，但就是没有火鸡。哇。真是个糟糕的故事，对吧？我只是觉得你很乐意跟公众分享这个。对，不过我说过，从那以后我们就不吃恐龙了。我们当然没吃。鸟类是。但我们确实有一个节日传统。
We've got a large plastic tyrannosaur, and we've made a little kind of Santa outfit for him. He joins the nativity scene. Oh, that's nice. So you've got the wise men, you've got the shepherds, and you've got... And got the dinosaur. You've got a tyrannosaur in a got the shepherds, and you've got... And got the dinosaur. You've got a tyrannosaur in a Santa Claus outfit.
我们有一个很大的塑料暴龙，我们给它做了一套小圣诞老人服装。它加入了耶稣诞生场景。哦，那挺好的。所以你有三智者，有牧羊人，还有……还有那只恐龙。你有一个穿着圣诞老人服装的暴龙。
How should we start? Should we start by discussing how historical are the gospel accounts? Okay. So, yes. So they're different, aren't they, the gospel accounts? So I think I'm right in saying you'll know more about this than me because you never miss an opportunity to plug your book about this in Christianity. Dominion, available from all good bookshops christmas coming up rush out and buy it folks well people are people have missed it i mean people have done their christmas shopping they
我们该怎么开始？我们要从讨论福音书的记载有多高的历史真实性开始吗？好吧。所以，是的。所以它们不一样，对吧，这些福音书的记载？所以我认为我说得没错，关于这个你比我懂得多，因为你从不错过任何推销你关于基督教这本书的机会。多米尼克，各大书店均有售，圣诞节快到了，大家快去抢购吧。好吧，人们已经，人们都错过了，我是说人们都已经买好圣诞节的东西了，他们
don't want to i mean maybe it's it'll be in the sales who knows um bookshops yeah isn't there a difference some gospels say uh he was born jesus was born in in Bethlehem and some say Nazareth. Is that right? No, so there are four Gospels and there are only two that give us accounts of the nativity. Both of them have him being born in Bethlehem. One of them, St. Matthew's Gospel, gives us the account of the three wise men coming and the massacre of the innocents. And the other one, Luke, gives us a story about the shepherds. Right.
不想，我是说也许它会在大减价时出现，谁知道呢……书店，是的，难道没有区别吗？有些福音书说，呃，他出生，耶稣出生在伯利恆（Bethlehem），有些说在拿撒勒（Nazareth）。是这样吗？不，所以有四部福音书，其中只有两部记载了耶稣诞生。这两部都说他出生在伯利恆。其中一部，即《马太福音》（St. Matthew's Gospel），记载了三位智者来访和屠杀无辜婴儿的故事。另一部，《路加福音》（Luke），则讲述了牧羊人的故事。没错。
And so the Christmas story is a fusion of the two. So there's no story in which you get both the shepherds and the wise men. No, no. And there are huge issues with it as history. The obvious one would be that the dates are all over the place. So obviously, we, you know, we date our years from the birth of Christ, but we've got no idea really when the birth of Christ is. Because in one of them, we've got King Herod is alive, and Herod dies in 4 BC. And then in the other one, we've got a decree going for from Caesar Augustus. And we're told that this is when Cyrenius was governor of Syria. And Cyrenius is holding his census in
所以圣诞故事是这两者的融合。因此，并没有一个故事里同时出现牧羊人和智者。没有，没有。作为历史，这里面有巨大的问题。显而易见的一个问题是，日期完全对不上。很显然，我们，你知道的，我们以基督诞生来纪年，但我们其实根本不知道基督是什么时候诞生的。因为在其中一本里，希律王（King Herod）还活着，而希律王死于公元前4年。而在另一本里，我们看到凯撒·奥古斯都（Caesar Augustus）颁布了一道法令。并且我们被告知，这是居里扭（Cyrenius）担任叙利亚总督的时候。而居里扭正在进行人口普查，时间是
AD 6. So you can't square the two. Okay, that's a pretty big range. Did that census actually happen, Tom? Is that a real thing? Well, there was a kind of census, but it certainly wasn't a census in the way that it gets described in the New Testament. And what's absolutely certain is that Joseph would not have been required to go to Bethlehem. And it's pretty clear that that whole story is an attempt to get Jesus to Bethlehem in trying to be born, because prophecy says that the Messiah will be born in Bethlehem. So they've retrofitted the story, basically. They've retrofitted the story.
公元6年。所以这两者根本对不上。好吧，这个时间跨度相当大。那次人口普查真的发生过吗，汤姆？那是真的吗？嗯，确实有过某种人口普查，但绝对不是新书里所描述的那种人口普查。而且可以完全确定的是，约瑟（Joseph）根本不需要去伯利恆。很明显，整个故事只是为了让耶稣在伯利恆出生而进行的安排，因为预言说弥赛亚（Messiah）将诞生于伯利恆。所以他们基本上是后来硬把故事套上去的。他们是硬把故事套上去的。
I mean, I think it's pretty clear that Jesus was born in Nazareth. But having said that, I think that you can see that there are kind of enduring themes that will run probably over the 2,000 years that have followed and which are part of the christian tradition to this day one is the idea that um jesus son of god the messiah is is essentially i mean he's he's the son of um travelers who can't find room in the inn famously he's laid in a in a manger and the contrast is something that is fundamental to the Christmas story, that God himself has become this tiny baby laid in a stable. So that's that's crucial. The contrast between greatness and smallness. And that's, I think, why the references to Caesar Augustus and to the Roman governorship and everything and to Herod is so important,
我的意思是，我认为很明显耶稣是出生在拿撒勒的。话虽如此，我认为你可以看出，有些持久的主题可能会貫穿随后的两千年，并且直到今天仍然是基督教传统的一部分。其中一个主题是，呃，耶稣——上帝之子、弥赛亚——本质上，我的意思是，他是呃旅人的儿子，他们找不到客栈的房间，著名的故事里他被放在马槽里。这种对比是圣诞故事的核心，即上帝本人变成了这个躺在马厩里的小婴儿。所以这是至关重要的。伟大与渺小的对比。这就是为什么提到凯撒·奥古斯都、罗马总督以及希律王如此重要，
because you're counterpointing that you're counterpointing um the Christ child to the apparatus of state power um and the other thing is the is the preaching of the message of peace which the angels tell to the shepherds um yeah and again this is placing the birth of Jesus in the context of Roman power, again, the kind of apparatus of Roman power. And again, it's the kind of counterpoint between the peace of heaven that Christ is bringing, counterpointed to that of the earth that can't. And again, that is a theme that runs throughout Christian history, the idea that Christmas properly should be a period of peace, should be a truce. And we may come to that later on. And during all this, so well, during the first couple of hundred years, so when Christianity is not, you know, a state religion or anything like that, did Christmas loom as large
因为你在进行对比，你将基督圣婴与国家机器的权势进行对比……而另一个主题是宣讲和平的信息，天使把这个信息告诉了牧羊人……是的，同样，这也是将耶稣的诞生置于罗马权力的背景之下，再次展现了罗马权力的那种机器。而且，这也是天堂降临的基督所带来的和平，与人间无法实现的和平之间的一种对比。这也是贯穿整个基督教历史的一个主题，即圣诞节本来应该是一个和平的时期，应该是一个休战期。我们稍后可能会谈到这一点。在这期间，好吧，在前几百年里，当基督教还不是（你知道的）国教或诸如此类的东西时，圣诞节对早期基督徒来说，
to the early Christians as it does to us? Or was it Easter that was the big deal? No, Christmas does not seem to have been marked or celebrated in the certainly first two centuries. It's probably late third century, beginning of the fourth century. And it's fixed on the 25th of December, as we all know. And we've had a couple of quite a few questions on this, actually. So Josie Wells speaks for many and says, how much influence did Saturnalia have on Christmas? Right, so Saturnalia, you know all about this. So this is this big Roman jamboree, isn't it? Yeah, so that's the Festival of Saturn,
有像对我们这样占据如此重要的地位吗？还是说复活节才是重头戏？不，在最初的两个世纪里，圣诞节似乎并没有被标记或庆祝。它大概出现在公元三世纪末、四世纪初。而且就像我们都知道的那样，它被固定在12月25日。其实我们关于这个已经收到了好几个甚至不少问题。乔西·韦尔斯（Josie Wells）代表了许多人的心声，她问：农神节对圣诞节有多大的影响？好吧，所以农神节，你对这个很了解。所以这是罗马人的狂欢节，对吧？是的，那是农神节，
and that is celebrated on the 17th of December. And then there are festivities that last kind of two, five, seven days after it. And it's often said that Christmas is is a kind of christianization of this festival or it's said that um the god mithras was born on the 25th of december or sol invictus the unconquered son of celebrated on the 25th of december yeah um i don't think that any of those reasons are adequate to explain why the church fixes on the 25th of december and it's again it's to do with this idea that the calendar is a fraction of the kind of divine purposes
是在12月17日庆祝的。在那之后还有持续两到五天甚至七天的庆祝活动。人们常说圣诞节是对这个节日的基督教化，或者说人们认为神明密特拉（Mithras）出生在12月25日，或者无敌太阳神（Sol Invictus）在12月25日被庆祝。是的，呃，我认为这些理由都不足以解释为什么教会将日期固定在12月25日。这其实与日历是神圣意志的一部分这种观念有关，
and it is actually determined by the date that the church arrives for the death of christ which is the 25th of march okay church fathers work out by the end of the second century that this is the likeliest date the 25th of march and as a tolkien fan you will remember that is that when the ring is the ring is thrown in on the 25th of march because tolkien knew that this was this was the holy day and everything comes back to tolkien doesn't it in history ultimately well so and the rabbis and christians both kind of thought that um things that begun and things that end happen on the same day so um the world begins the world will end on the same day and so christians assume that the day of christ's birth sorry the the day of christ's death must also have been the day of the incarnation, the day in which
它实际上是由教会确定的基督受难日决定的，也就是3月25日。好吧，教会神父们在二世纪末计算出这最可能是个日期，即3月25日。作为一个托尔金（Tolkien）迷，你会记得，至尊戒就是在3月25日被扔进去的，因为托尔金知道这是一个神圣的日子。一切都归结于托尔金，不是吗？历史最终都指向他。好吧，所以犹太法学家和基督徒都认为，开始的事情和结束的事情发生在同一天，所以，呃，世界开始的日子和世界结束的日子是同一天。因此，基督徒认为，基督诞生的日子——抱歉，基督受难的日子也必然是道成肉身的日子，也就是
the Spirit enters Mary and Jesus is implanted in the womb. And then you take nine months from the 25th of March and you get to the 25th of December. But Tom, I'm going to press you on this. This seems a little bit... I can understand. Okay, I can buy all that stuff about dating back, but it's a remarkable coincidence, very convenient, that it happens to coincide with this huge Roman blowout. And also, I think I'm right in saying with the big day of Sol Invictus, which is one of, you know, it's one of Christianity's big rivals, isn't it? At the point where Christianity is sweeping its way through the Roman Empire,
圣灵进入玛丽体内、耶稣在子宫内孕育的日子。然后你从3月25日往后推九个月，就得到了12月25日。但是汤姆，我要向你追问这一点。这似乎有点……我可以理解。好吧，我可以接受关于日期推算的所有说法，但这真是一个非同寻常的巧合，而且非常方便，它刚好与罗马人的这场巨大狂欢重合了。而且，据我所知，它也与无敌太阳神的盛大节日重合了，而无敌太阳神是基督教的一大强劲对手，不是吗？在基督教席卷罗马帝国的时期，
that basically Christianity, you know, it sort of steals the, I mean, you can't tell me this complete coincidence that it steals the big day of one of its competitor religions. Well, on Sol Invictus, it's unclear exactly whether it was celebrated on the 25th of December, because as you all know, the sources for these kinds of things are incredibly complicated. And there is actually, there's a kind of an amazing account that says very boldly that the Christians moved it on to 25th December because they wanted to appropriate the feast of the unconquered son and it was thought that this came from the 4th century but it's subsequently been shown that actually it dates from the 12th century and it's written in the margins of an
基本上，基督教，你知道的，它有点窃取了，我是说，你不能告诉我这完全是巧合，它窃取了其竞争宗教之一的盛大节日。好吧，关于无敌太阳神，目前还不清楚它是否真的在12月25日庆祝，因为正如大家所知，这类事情的历史资料极其复杂。而且实际上，有一个令人惊异的记载非常大胆地声称，基督徒将其改到12月25日是因为他们想据为己有无敌太阳神的节日，人们曾认为这出自公元4世纪，但随后证明它实际上可追溯到公元12世纪，写在一个叙利亚主教的记载的页边空白处。
account by a Syrian bishop. And essentially it's an attempt to explain why the Western Church celebrates Christmas on the 25th of December, whereas the Eastern Church celebrates it quite later. And so essentially we have we don't really have any solid evidence at all that the birthday of Solomon Victus was on the 25th of December. Certainly none that the birthday of Solomon Victus was on the 25th of December certainly none that the birthday of Mithras was on the 25th of December okay having said that having said that it is clear that the the solstice the winter solstice the dead of of the year is clearly a time when people do want to cheer themselves up I mean we see that at the moment the debate over whether to celebrate Christmas in the midst of the pandemic or not yeah and it's clear as well so there's a there's that we have a question here from um rob landy who says what's the connection to yule given that apparently primary sources
这本质上是为了解释为什么西方教会会在12月25日庆祝圣诞节，而东方教会则庆祝得晚得多。所以本质上，我们其实没有任何确凿的证据表明无敌太阳神的生日是在12月25日。当然也没有证据表明密特拉的生日是在12月25日。好吧，话虽如此，话虽如此，很明显，冬至，也就是一年中最黑暗、最死寂的时刻，确实是人们想要让自己高兴起来的时刻。我们现在也能看到这一点，关于是否要在疫情期间庆祝圣诞节的争论，是的。而且也很明显，我们这里有一个来自罗布·兰迪（Rob Landy）的问题，他问：鉴于原始资料并没有详细记载，这与北欧冬至节（Yule）有什么联系？
don't go into detail absolutely right and can we really claim that santa is actually odin or is it just speculation based on a couple of common attributes we might come to santa later but there are these kind of feet you and um i guess the kind of you know going right the way back the alignment of stonehenge to the winter solstice that kind of thing um it's evident that the desire to celebrate a festival of light in the depth of darkness is a kind of universal thing i guess the the church fathers would have said well this is purely providential this shows yeah i've got a remarkable accident what a lucky coincidence yes and then so for the first what what are we looking at the first 1500 years even
绝对没错。我们真的能断言圣诞老人其实就是奥丁（Odin），还是这仅仅是基于几个共同特征的猜测？我们可能稍后会谈到圣诞老人，但确实有这些节日，呃，我想，一直追溯到巨石阵与冬至的对齐，诸如此类的事情……显然，在黑暗深处庆祝光明节的愿望是一种普遍的现象。我想，教会的神父们会说，这纯粹是上天的眷顾，这表明——是的，真是个了不起的意外，多么幸运的巧合。是的。那么，在前，我们看到的是前1500年甚至更长时间里，
of christmas's existence as a festival it's basically you know people always moan now or have lost the true spirit of christmas which is sort of silent contemplation and thinking about peace and sort of you know living you know living Jeremy Corbyn's life in a day and um and actually that's never really been what Christmas is about has it because for most of that sort of first 1500 years it was about stuffing yourself with food getting drunk having a party messing about the sort of the mis, the carnivalesque element of Christmas. I mean, that, in a weird way, is what we've lost, actually. Yeah, but it's also about, I think that it's about the idea of the wealthy, those with power, offering generosity to those who lack it.
作为节日的圣诞节的存在，基本上，你知道的，人们现在总是抱怨或者已经失去了圣诞节的真正精神，也就是那种安静的沉思、思考和平以及，你知道的，过着杰里·科宾（Jeremy Corbyn）一天的生活。而实际上，这从来都不是圣诞节的真正意义，对吧？因为在最初的1500年里，圣诞节是为了大吃大喝、酩酊大醉、开派对、胡闹，带有圣诞狂欢的色彩。从某种奇怪的角度来看，这其实才是我们所失去的东西。是的，但我也认为，这关乎富人、掌权者向缺乏资源的人提供慷慨。
So one of my favourite Anglo-Saxon charters is issued by Athelstan. You have a favourite Anglo-Saxon charter. That's great. Of course you do. I would expect nothing else. Of course. And it's issued by Athelstan on Christmas Eve to one of his noblemen, issuing a grant of land, and specifies that you can have this land, but if you get anybody coming into your land who needs shelter, you have to provide them with shelter and it's pretty clear that um Athelstan has been contemplating the Christmas story and that's what's at the back of his mind and that's kind of incredibly moving because suddenly you get a kind of you know shaft of light into the way that this otherwise um very obscure king
所以，我最喜欢的盎格鲁-撒克逊（Anglo-Saxon）宪章之一是由埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）发布的。你居然有一个最喜欢的盎格鲁-撒克逊宪章。太棒了。你当然有。我料到你会这样。当然。这是埃塞尔斯坦在平安夜颁布给他的一个贵族的，授予了一块土地，并明确规定你可以拥有这块土地，但如果有任何人来到你的土地上需要庇护，你必须为他们提供庇护。很明显，埃塞尔斯坦一直在思考圣诞节的故事，这正是他脑海中所想的。这非常感人，因为突然之间，你看到了一道光芒照进了一个原本非常模糊的国王的生活中。
I mean we have no kind of insight into the way that he thinks. But suddenly we do with this and it's very moving. And I think that the traditions of celebration at Christmas, where the halls are opened up and, as you say, kind of feasting and merrymaking, the crucial aspect of the merrymaking from the Christian point of view is that it is a shared celebration. It's the rich hosting the poor. And that, again, I think is a theme that runs right the way through into the present day. I mean, it is a kind of, I mean, as a kind of modern historian, wouldn't you say that the idea of giving does actually remain pretty fundamental to the way that Christmas is understood. A little bit though actually I mean we're sort of leaping ahead here because I wanted to sort of save all this for when we got to the Victorians but I mean I think the big shift in
我是说，我们无法深入了解他的想法。但通过这个，我们突然可以了，这非常感人。我认为圣诞节的庆祝传统——敞开大门，如你所说的大吃大喝、寻欢作乐——从基督教的角度来看，最关键的一点在于它是一个共享的庆祝活动。这是富有的人招待穷人。我认为，这也是一个一直延续到今天的核心主题。我的意思是，作为一个现代历史学家，难道你不认为赠予的理念实际上仍然是人们理解圣诞节的一个相当基础的部分吗？其实也有一点……好吧，我们这里有点跳跃了，因为我本来想把这些都留到我们讲到维多利亚时代的时候再说的。但我认为圣诞节的巨大转变实际上是从集体走向私人。所以我觉得你说得对，那种开放的、公共性质的狂欢，一直延续到……你知道的，基本上到了一首圣诞颂歌（A Christmas Carol），然后我认为——好吧，我们等会儿会讲到这个——我认为圣诞节发生的变化是，圣诞节退守到了封闭的门后，变成了一个更加私密化、家常化的节日。而实际上，那种给予穷人的慈善和社区意识随着时间推移而减弱了。不过没关系，我们待会儿会深入探讨这个。我只是想提出一个来自格林肖古典与拉丁语（Greenshaw Classics and Latin）的问题，格林肖说他们想问的是人们出于某种非——他们称之为“非圣诞节”的原因来利用圣诞节。你
Christmas is actually from the collective to the private so I think you're right that the that the sort of open the public nature of of um going all the way through to you know basically to a Christmas carol and then I think with well I mean we're going to come to this later but I think what's happened with Christmas is Christmas has retreated behind closed doors and become a much more privatized sort of domesticated um festival and actually the sort of you know the giving to the poor and the sort of sense of community has become diminished over time but anyway we'll get into this a little bit later i just wanted to bring up a question from greenshaw classics and latin and greenshaw says they want to ask about the use of christmas for sort of non what it called they call non-christmassy reasons so you
提到了埃塞尔斯坦，我想问关于人们在圣诞节加冕的事，比如征服者威廉（William the Conqueror）或查理曼（Charlemagne）——他们都是在圣诞节（12月25日）加冕的。这只是个巧合吗？还是说这是一个刻意选择，旨在将他们的政权与基督的诞生联系起来？说句老实话，我不知道。但我猜是的。但我猜是的。这是历史上的一个重要时刻。我猜是的，因为我认为教会的节日在前现代时期有着我们现在几乎无法理解的重要意义。是的。
mentioned athelstan i wanted to ask about the coronation of people at william the conqueror or charlemagne so they're both crowned on on Christmas Day on the 25th of December. And is that just a fluke? Or is that a deliberate choice to identify their regime with the birth of Christ? I'm going to be absolutely honest, I have no idea. But I would guess so. But I would guess so. This is a great moment in history. I would guess it because I think that the feast days of the church have a salience in kind of pre-modern times that we can barely comprehend now. Yeah.
从某种意义上说，圣诞节对我们的意义，是那个世界仅存的一个幽灵般的遗迹——在那个世界里，你的整个生活都是由这些节日构成的。是的，你通过它们的流逝来衡量季节，通过它们的流逝来衡量你自己的生活。因此，那种日历反映了一种宇宙戏剧的感觉，使得圣诞节当天发生的事情具有了这种难以置信的重要意义。我猜一定是的，但让我们把这个抛出来，让那些比我懂得更多的人来回答这个问题。好吧，我想如果你是一个政治家，而且你打算在12月中下旬的某个时候加冕，你肯定会选择25日，对吧？
And in a sense, the significance of Christmas for us is the kind of one ghostly remains of that world where your whole life was structured by these festivals yes you measure out the seasons by you measure out your own life by their passage and so what happened the sense that um the calendar is reflecting a kind of cosmic drama and so what happens on christmas day has this incredible significance i would guess it must do but let's let's put that that out and uh yeah people that's people who know more than I do to answer that question. Well, I suppose if you're a politician and you're going to be crowned at some point in the mid-20s December, you're going to choose the 25th, aren't you?
这就顺理成章了，因为那天本来就是个节日。还能省点钱。是的，没错。两个节日并为一个，这样可以省事。所以我们稍微快进一下，因为我们之前讨论了圣诞节的公共性质、狂欢以及其他种种，这不可避免地把我们带到了宗教改革和清教徒时期。他们基本上看着——我想现在人们对他们禁止圣诞节存在完全错误的理解。我的意思是，我想他们想要镇压圣诞节是因为，你知道的，因为它不够基督教化，因为它的基督教色彩还不够浓厚。
It just sort of makes sense that it's a feast day already. We save money. Yeah, exactly. Two feasts where you can have one so let's fast forward a little bit um because we've obviously talked about the sort of public nature of christmas and the merrymaking and all the rest and this inevitably brings up the you know you get to the period of the reformation and the puritans who basically look at now i think people got completely the wrong idea about them banning Christmas. I mean, what they want, I think they want to clamp down on Christmas because, you know, because it's not Christian, because it's not Christian enough.
因为基本上他们看着人们的行为，然后说，这些人除了喝得烂醉、举止不得体、对人动手动脚、自取其辱之外，什么都没做。事实上，有趣的是，他们认为圣诞节应该只是个普通日子，不是吗？他们想让人们去上班。嗯，是的，不过有趣的是，圣诞节是对异教节日的一种接管这种观点，其实正是始于宗教改革家，始于清教徒。这是他们极其焦虑的一点。所以在清教徒声讨圣诞节的文章中，你一次又一次地看到人们在做什么的清单：玩纸牌，吃坚果似乎是一个特别的……我看到过人们吃坚果过量的现象，
Because basically they look at what people are doing and they say, well, all they're doing is they're getting hammered and sort of dancing inappropriately and, you know, groping people and disgracing themselves. And actually, the interesting thing, though, is that they think Christmas should just be an ordinary day, don't they? They want people to go to work. Well, yeah, but also, interestingly, the whole idea that Christmas is a kind of takeover of pagan festivals actually begins with the reformers, it begins with the Puritans. It's something that they're incredibly anxious about and so again and again in um you know puritan screeds against christmas you get lists of what people are doing kind of playing cards i think eating nuts seems to be a particular i've seen excess with people eating nuts yeah um maybe they've got allergy kind of merry making masking mumming caroling dicing all
也许他们对坚果过敏吧。寻欢作乐、戴面具、假面游行、唱颂歌、掷骰子，所有这些东西，他们说，这些都是异教徒做的事。所以他们去查阅关于农神节等节日发生了什么的记载，然后说，我们在让异教神灵重新潜入。当人们以这种方式庆祝圣诞节时，他们实际上是在庆祝萨图恩（Saturn）或巴克科斯（Bacchus）或其他什么神。这就是他们的焦虑所在。所以，我认为今年让我们对这一点有了更深刻的理解。因为事实上，我们又回到了那种紧张状态：你究竟该偏重庆祝活动、节日的狂欢方面？还是该专注于拯救生命、核心信息——对于清教徒来说，这全关乎生死。
that kind of stuff um and they say this is the kind of stuff that the pagans did so they're through and reading up accounts of what happened at the saturnalia and so on and saying you know we we are allowing the pagan gods to creep back in and when people celebrate christmas in this way actually what they're doing is they're celebrating Saturn or Bacchus or whoever. And that's the anxiety. And so again, and I think that this year has really sharpened our understanding of that. Because actually, we are back to a kind of tension where do you privilege the celebration, the festive aspects of it? Or do you focus on kind of saving life, the kind of core message, which for Puritans, you know, it was all about life and death.
这关乎你是否能从地狱中被救赎。所以2020年的这场辩论，我认为让我们突然更容易理解17世纪时到底发生了什么，尤其是护国公时期（Protectorate），这是一个臭名昭著的例子。是的。好吧，有很多这样的故事，不是吗，
It was about whether you were going to be redeemed from hell. And so that debate in 2020, I think it is suddenly much easier for us to fathom what was going on in the, well, you know, aspects, particularly the protectorate and the, it is the notorious example. Yeah. Well, there's all these stories, aren't there,
关于议会在圣诞节当天工作。汤姆，你在圣诞节工作过吗？我从来没有在圣诞节工作过。我真的很喜欢圣诞节。是的，我也是。其实我非常迷圣诞节。我很喜欢莫康和怀斯（Morecambe and Wise）的圣诞特别节目，
about Parliament working on Christmas Day. Have you ever worked on Christmas Day, Tom? I've never worked on Christmas Day. I really love Christmas. Yeah, me too. I'm a real sucker for Christmas, actually. I really buy into all the, you know, Morecambe and Wise Christmas special,
所有那些伟大的传统。当然。我知道我从来没有……不过我妻子是个助产士，所以她要……是的，所以今年她得出去值夜班，从五点开始……哦，太令人印象深刻了，但那个孩子就要出生了，这就是圣诞节的意义所在，所以，是的……让我们回到清教徒那里吧。奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell），每个人都认为奥利弗·克伦威尔禁止了圣诞节，但当然，奥利弗·克伦威尔甚至都不在权力中心。我的意思是，在议会禁止圣诞节的时候，他正带着他的“铁骑军”（Ironsides）在野外骑马四处征战，不是吗？因为是议会禁止的，而不是克伦威尔的护国公政权。
all the great time-honoured traditions. Absolutely. I know I've never but whereas my wife is a midwife she so she does um yeah so uh this year she's got to go out and do uh do shift at five so oh very impressive but that baby's been born that's that's that's what Christmas is as well so yeah um let's go back to the Puritans though so Oliver Cromwell everybody thinks Oliver Cromwell banned Christmas but of course Oliver Cromwell, everybody thinks Oliver Cromwell banned Christmas. But of course, Oliver Cromwell wasn't even in power. I mean, he was out in the field somewhere riding around with his ironsides at the point that Parliament banned Christmas, wasn't it? Because it was Parliament that banned it, not the Cromwellian Protectorate.
有趣的是，你知道的，有各种各样的记载说人们像往常一样去上班，实际上还有争论说——有些想过圣诞节的愤怒的学徒试图强迫别人关门歇业、去寻欢作乐，而别人根本不想。所以，这就有点像……你可以想象一下，新冠疫情期间的“封锁反对者”在乡间游荡，试图强迫商店开门——好吧，不是让商店在圣诞节开门，而是试图强迫人们与家人见面、看更多的电视、吃更多的土耳其软糖。是的，这显然是鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）心中查理二世（Charles II）与克伦威尔之间激烈的内心斗争。是的。
And the interesting thing is that, you know, there are all these accounts of sort of people going to work as normal and actually arguments about whether you know so so irate apprentices who want to have christmas are trying to force people to shut their shops and enjoy themselves when they don't want to um so sort of yeah as you're trying to imagine kind of um covid you know lockdown deniers roaming the land trying to force shops to open to well not shops to open on christmas day but trying trying to force people to meet their families and to watch more TV and eat more Turkish delight. Yeah, and that's the kind of, obviously, the great inner struggle going on in Boris Johnson's heart between Charles II and Cromwell. Yeah.
你知道的，他会站在哪一边？我认为，正如我所说，这场危机确实让我们聚焦了圣诞节在17世纪时的重要意义。以及那种一直存在的紧张关系：一方面是带着应有的庄严来纪念基督教历法中这个极其神圣的时刻，另一方面人们又觉得，也许纪念这种庄严最好的方式就是好好玩乐一番。是的。然后，理所当然地，王政复辟发生了，圣诞节回归了。所以，庆祝活动重新开始，其余种种也随之恢复。
You know, who's he going to side with? And I think that, you know, as I said, I think that this whole crisis does focus for us what the significance of Christmas was back in the 17th century as well. And that kind of the tension that has always existed between it being marking this incredibly holy moment in the Christian calendar with all due solemnity. And yet people feeling that perhaps the best way to mark that solemnity is to have a great time. Yes. And then, of course, the restoration happens and Christmas returns. So, you know, the festivities restart and all the rest of it.
然而在我看来，圣诞节最有趣的地方在于接下来的那一百年里圣诞节发生了什么，因为那是故事中从未被讲述过的一部分。实际上，有趣的是，如果你去查阅当时的资料，人们在日记中几乎很少提到它。它是一个瞻礼日，是一个节日，但其中带有一种轻微的倒退感。
And yet, to me, the interesting thing about Christmas is what happens to Christmas in the next hundred years because that's a part of the story just never gets told. And actually, the interesting thing looking into it is that often people barely mention it in their diaries. It's a feast day and it's a festival, but there's something slightly backward about it.
它基本上是人们紧紧抓住的过去的一种遗迹，尤其是在乡间。而且，你知道的，圣诞节是一件很老派的事情，但并不是什么大不了的事。远没有今天这么轰动。是的，我觉得这是一种，
It's basically a relic of the past that they're kind of clinging on to, particularly in the countryside. And there's a, you know, Christmas is a sort of old fashioned thing, but it's not a massive deal. Nowhere near as big a deal as it is today. Yeah, I think it's a kind of,
我们，英国人把圣诞节的传统庆祝活动出口到了美国。然后我觉得它又从美国被带回了英国。我认为美国庆祝圣诞节的传统，基本上至少可以追溯到19世纪初。所以这几乎是美国化的第一个例子。这也将非常顺理成章地把我们引向圣诞老人，以及他是否真的是奥丁的转世。但在我们进入这个迷人的话题之前，先休息一下吧。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的地方。
we, the English export the traditional celebration of Christmas to America. And I think it then gets brought back to England from America. And I think that the American traditions of celebrating Christmas, I mean, basically they stem at least from the early 19th century. So it's kind of almost the first example of Americanization. And that will bring us on very neatly to Santa Claus and whether indeed he is a reincarnation of Odin. But let's have a break before we get onto that
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们正在讨论圣诞老人（Father Christmas 或 Santa Claus）。汤姆，你是“圣诞老人（Father Christmas）”派的还是“山羊胡圣诞老人（Santa Claus）”派的？我是“圣诞老人（Father Christmas）”派的，我讨厌“山羊胡圣诞老人（Santa Claus）”。
fascinating topic. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we are talking father christmas or santa claus tom are you a santa claus man or a father christmas man i'm a father christmas man i hate santa claus
一个地道的英国人。我也是“圣诞老人（Father Christmas）”派的。太好了，我就知道你会是。我就知道你会是。我愿意认为我们的听众都是“圣诞老人（Father Christmas）”派的，也许还有一些“尼古拉斯（Nick）”死忠粉吧。所以，圣尼古拉斯的传说是很大的，这就是它的起源。所以我们刚才在讨论罗布·兰迪的一个问题：圣诞老人实际上是奥丁吗？不，我不认为他是。这可以追溯到华盛顿·欧文（Washington Irving），这位19世纪初的美国短篇小说家，他是一个圣诞节迷，他感叹了你刚才所谈到的现象，即节日似乎正在走向衰落，它与男爵庄园之类的事物联系在一起。很显然，美国并没有那些东西。
a true born englishman i'm also a father christmas man good i knew you would be i knew you would be i like to think that our listeners are all father christmas uh maybe some nick maybe a few nick diehards yeah so say nick is is big i mean that's how it starts so we were talking about whether a question from rob landy is is um father christmas um actually odin no yeah i i don't think he is um and it it goes back to uh this washington irving the america short story teller beginning of the 19th century who is a sucker for christmas and he laments what you were talking about the fact that um the festival seems to be going into decline that it's associated with baronial halls and things like that. And obviously you don't have those in America.
那么，如果没有男爵庄园，圣诞节就会走向毁灭吗？是的，他对此非常担忧。但他所在的圈子实际上对复兴古老的欧洲传统非常感兴趣，而圣尼古拉斯实际上与荷兰人的到来联系在一起。是的，所以尼古拉斯是荷兰的，对吧？我的意思是，他是希腊-土耳其圣徒在荷兰的演变。所以欧文在1809年写了《纽约外史》（History of New York），
And so is Christmas doomed if you don't have a baronial hall? Yeah. And he's very worried about this. But he's part of a circle that are actually very interested in kind of resurrecting old European traditions. And St. Nicholas is actually associated with the coming of the Dutch. Yeah, so Nicholas is Dutch, right? I mean, he's a Dutch adoption of a Greek-Turkish saint. So Irving writes the history of New York in 1809,
他指出停泊在曼哈顿岸边的第一艘荷兰船只就以圣尼古拉斯作为船头雕像。随后，这被他的一个朋友克莱门特·克拉克·摩尔（Clement Clarke Moore）所采纳。克莱门特·克拉克·摩尔写了《圣尼古拉斯来了》（The Night Before Christmas），描写了圣尼古拉斯的到来，他确实把圣尼古拉斯描述为一个精灵。所以这可能带有一种虚构的连续感，与那些斯堪的纳维亚传统或产生奥丁的传统联系在一起。但摩尔是一位神学院的讲师。所以他非常、非常……
and he notes that the very first Dutch ship to moor off Manhattan had St. Nicholas as its figurehead. And this then gets picked up by a friend of his called Clement Clarke Mooreore who is um night before christmas the night before christmas and writes about saint nicholas saint nick coming and he does describe saint nick as as an elf so there is perhaps a kind of uh invented sense of continuity with those scandinavian traditions or whatever that also give you Odin. But Moore is a lecturer in a theological seminary. So he's very, very...
怎么总绕不开基督教，对吧？是的，总是绕不开基督教。我恐怕是的。恐怕是的。很显然，圣尼古拉斯的目的是试图重新引入这种赠予礼物的中世纪传统、开放的好客传统、用冬青树装饰树枝以及所有诸如此类的传统。事实证明，这取得了难以置信的成功。但他并不是“Father Christmas”，对吧？“Father Christmas”是另一个人，对吗？
It's always Christianity with you, isn't it? Yeah, it's always Christianity. I'm afraid. I'm afraid. And so it's clear that the purpose of St. Nick is an attempt to re-import this kind of medieval tradition of giving gifts, of open hospitality, of decking the bowels with holly and all that kind of thing tradition of giving gifts, of open hospitality, of decking the bounds with holly and all that kind of thing. And it proves incredibly successful. But he's not Father Christmas, though. Father Christmas is somebody else, right?
“Father Christmas”是英国本土的。所以“Father Christmas”是圣诞节和欢乐的一种英国本土化拟人形象。而圣尼古拉斯则稍有不同。我没说错吧，圣尼古拉斯的到来，你知道的，他们虽然不尽相同，但他们来自不同的起源，对吗？
Father Christmas is English. So Father Christmas is this sort of English personification of Christmas, of jollity. And St. Nicholas is slightly different. Am I right that St. Nicholas has come, you know, they're not dissimilar, but they've come from different sort of, from different origins?
是的，所以圣尼古拉斯的传统被出口回了英国，并与“Father Christmas”的传统融合在了一起，就像灰松鼠融合……我正要这么说。圣诞老人就是一个男版的灰松鼠。因此，这并不是英国传统第一次被美国传统所湮没。
Yeah, so that tradition of St. Nicholas gets exported back to Britain and merges with the tradition of Father Christmas, rather as grey squirrels merge. I was just about to say that. Santa Claus is a grey squirrel of a man. So not for the first time an English tradition gets blotted out by the American tradition.
是的。然后显然，你接着说。嗯，我本来想问你，因为之后，当然还有德国的输入，对吧？是的。我想之前……乔治三世（George III）的妻子夏洛特王后（Queen Charlotte）曾带来过一棵圣诞树，人们当时看着它说，天哪，居然有树，接下来还会有什么。但显然阿尔伯特亲王（Prince Albert）才是关键人物。
Yes. And then obviously, go on, you go. Well, I was going to ask you, because then, of course, also, then there are German imports, aren't there? Yes. And I think there had been... So I think George III's wife, Queen Charlotte, had brought a Christmas tree and people had sort of looked at it and said, golly, a tree, whatever next. But obviously Prince Albert is the key figure.
他是维多利亚女王（Queen Victoria）的丈夫，也就是王夫。他非常热衷于他那日耳曼风格的传统。他带来了圣诞树，人们为此感到非常兴奋，因为人们当然都在模仿皇室。我认为这实际上是19世纪圣诞节重塑的关键所在——维多利亚和阿尔伯特将君主制重新包装为一个理想化的家庭，一个温馨的小家庭单位，以及圣诞节那种温馨舒适（Gemütlichkeit）的氛围。所以我们收到了一个来自“文化胡萝卜”（Culture Carrot）的问题，他问：难道真的是我们的德国皇室基本上促成了这一切吗？所以你的意思是是的？
So he's Queen Victoria's husband, the prince consort. He's very into his sort of Germanic, you know, traditions. And he brings over a Christmas tree and people get very excited because of course people are modeling themselves on the on the sort of royal family and i think that's actually the key to christmas and christmas's reinvention in the 19th century is this idea i mean victoria and albert rebranded the monarchy as an idealized family as this little family unit and the sort of cosiness and the gemütlichkeit kind of aspect of Christmas. So we have a question from Culture Carrot who asks, was it our German royal family who basically did that? So you're saying it is?
嗯，我认为他们将其人格化并推动了它的发展。但如果没有他们，这一切会发生吗？我想它还是会发生。我们之前谈到了圣诞节的变化，我认为这是一个重大的改变，即从公共仪式向私人家庭化转变。我认为出现这种情况的原因是，当时已经有了工业城市社会。换句话说，人们不再生活在那种聚集在男爵庄园里、由庄园领主分发礼物的乡村社区里。他们住在伦敦的联排别墅里，维多利亚时代的联排别墅里。他们在工厂工作，而圣诞节则成了家庭时光的绿洲。这就是为什么圣尼古拉斯或圣诞老人的形象如此完美，因为他是一个通过烟囱下来分发慷慨的形象。
Well, I think they personified it and they drove it forward. But would it have happened without them? I think it would have happened. And we talked earlier about the change from what i think is a big change of christmas which is a change from the public ceremony to the private family-based one and i think what you have there is you've got an industrial urban society so in other words people aren't living in these rural communities where they gather in the baronial hall and the sort of the lord of the manor gives them presents they They are in their, you know, terraced house, their Victorian terraced house in London. They work in the factory and Christmas becomes this oasis of sort of family time. And that's why the figure of Saint Nicholas of Santa Claus is so perfect for it because he's a figure dispensing generosity coming down a chimney.
顺着烟囱下来。他们有烟囱。你那小客厅里也有烟囱。圣诞精神就这样精准地进入了美满的家庭。显而易见，这正是在这个时候确定的。所以圣诞节的关键一年，我认为是1843年。因为两件事同时发生了：你有了第一张圣诞贺卡，同时你也有了一首圣诞颂歌。没错。好吧，所以是狄更斯（Dickens）。
Down the chimney. They've got chimneys. You've got a chimney in your little living room. And the spirit of Christmas exactly comes into the family home. And obviously, it's precise at this point. So you get the crucial year for Christmas, I think, is 1843. Because two things happen. You get the first Christmas card and you get a Christmas carol. Right. OK, so Dickens.
所以是狄更斯。他是如何融入其中的？我认为狄更斯绝对是至关重要的。我的意思是，狄更斯，他的精神弥漫整个19世纪以及19世纪的大众文化。通过《圣诞颂歌》，我的意思是，其中的许多元素都与《圣诞颂歌》息息相关。你知道的，你最近在其中一期播客里把他描述为一个反叛逆向思维的人。而这是你绝不能反其道而行之的一点，因为《圣诞颂歌》如此清晰地为圣诞节创造了模板。这是一个极其精彩的故事。
So Dickens. So how does he fit in? I think Dickens is absolutely crucial. I mean, I think Dickens, his spirit suffuses the 19th century and 19th century popular culture. And with the Christmas Carol, I mean, so many of the ingredients are bound up with the Christmas Carol. You know, you described him in one of the podcasts recently as contrarian. And this is one thing that you just can't be contrarian about because Christmas Carol so clearly creates the template for Christmas. It's a brilliant story.
我想，它已经变成了一个神话，不是吗？我的意思是，它真的已经变成了一个现代神话。我想我们都同意，对它最好的诠释就是布偶版《圣诞颂歌》（The Muppets' Christmas Carol）。我们确实如此。迈克尔·凯恩（Michael Caine）绝对是……
I think, you know, it's become a myth, hasn't it? I mean, it really has become a modern myth. I think we all agree that the best interpretation of it is the Muppets' Christmas Carol. We are. Michael Caine is by far,
我想，你知道的，它已经变成了一个神话，不是吗？我的意思是，它真的已经变成了一个现代神话。我想我们都同意，对它最好的演绎是《布偶圣诞颂歌》。我们确实是。迈克尔·凯恩无疑是
you know, his performance, his singing has screwedrooge is first class um and i and all the different aspects of it the you know the turkey i mean it's an interesting question actually we had from harry wallop online he said on christmas day at the climax of a christmas carol scrooge sends a boy out to buy a turkey i.e the shops are open and and actually that's a an interesting reminder that actually at that stage, Christmas wasn't, you know, it wasn't this sort of period of peace and contemplation. Things were open, things were going on, there was still a public element to it. But obviously, what you
你知道，他的表现，他的歌唱，他扮演的斯克鲁奇是一流的，嗯，我以及它的所有不同方面，你知道，那只火鸡，我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题，实际上是我们在网上收到的哈里·沃洛普提出的，他说在圣诞节那天，在《圣诞颂歌》的高潮时，斯克鲁奇派一个男孩去买一只火鸡，也就是说商店是开着的，实际上这是一个有趣的提醒，在那个阶段，圣诞节并不是那种和平与沉思的时期。事情是开放的，事情在继续，它仍然有公共元素。但显然，你
get is that that scene of the Cratchit family, they're all sitting around having their turkey. And this sort of, you know, they work so hard, and this is their one oasis of peace and happiness in an otherwise kind of grim, you know, Victorian sort of, you know, they've got 364 days of drudgery, and this is their one moment. And clearly a lot of people in mid-19th century Britain, and indeed around the industrialised world world really bought into that. They loved the idea of having this one little oasis. And, you know, thanks to Dickens with all his sort of brilliance of his creations and the ghosts and all the rest of it, you know, it caught on. There's a kind of classic Dickens tension, though, isn't there? That you've got Marley's ghost who arrives and he has this great chain of ledger boxes and things. So the idea that the process of making money is a chain and it dries
得到的是克拉切特一家的那个场景，他们都坐在那里吃火鸡。这就像，你知道，他们工作得如此努力，这是他们在原本有些冷酷的、维多利亚式的、你知道的364天的苦役中唯一的和平与幸福的绿洲，这是他们的唯一时刻。显然，19世纪中叶的英国有很多人，实际上整个工业化世界的人都真的很买账。他们喜欢拥有这一个小绿洲的想法。而且，你知道，多亏了狄更斯和他所有的创造力的光芒、鬼魂以及所有这些，你知道，它流行起来了。不过，这有一种经典的狄更斯式的紧张感，不是吗？你有马利的鬼魂到来，他带着一串巨大的账本盒子之类的东西。所以赚钱的过程是一个链条，它会榨干
you out and it leaves you kind of huddled over a candle inspecting your ledger book on Christmas Eve. But at the same time, it's precisely that that enables Scrooge to buy turkeys and everything and hold the festivities. Tom, you know what you're doing here? You're channeling your inner Margaret Thatcher, because this is your Margaret Thatcher, you know, no one will remember the Good Samaritan. Oh, right. I thought I was being Marxist there. Yeah, no, you're being, this is pure Thatcherism that, you know, no one would remember the Good Samaritan unless he'd had money as well. God, I'm being attacked by left-wing historian Dominic Sambra here. Exactly. You're basically saying, you know, Scrooge, if Scrooge hadn't been such a successful
你，让你在平安夜缩成一团围着蜡烛检查你的账本。但与此同时，恰恰是这一点使斯克鲁奇能够买火鸡和一切并举行庆祝活动。汤姆，你知道你在做什么吗？你在展现你内心深处的玛格丽特·撒切尔，因为这是你的玛格丽特·撒切尔，你知道，没有人会记得好撒玛利亚人。哦，对的。我还以为我在那里表现得很马克思主义。是的，不，你是，这是纯粹的撒切尔主义，你知道，除非好撒玛利亚人也有钱，否则没人会记得他。天哪，我正受到左翼历史学家多米尼克·桑布拉的攻击。没错。你基本上是在说，你知道，斯克鲁奇，如果斯克鲁奇不是那么成功
businessman, he wouldn't have been able to buy all this turkey. I'm not saying that. I'm not saying that. I'm saying that there is a tension there in Christmas Carol, as you get throughout Dickens's novels, where basically all the problems of industrial society are solved by benevolent philanthropists who pop up. Yeah so that's always the way Dickens is. I mean there is Dickens has absolutely zero interest in how you actually make money at all but clearly he is focusing in on something that is still very much present with us now which is that in a way Christmas is cast as a kind of an escape from the grind of
的商人，他就买不起所有这些火鸡。我不是这个意思。我不是这个意思。我的意思是，《圣诞颂歌》中存在着一种紧张关系，就像你在狄更斯的小说中到处都能看到的那样，工业社会的所有问题基本上都是由突然出现的仁慈慈善家解决的。是的，所以狄更斯一直都是这样。我的意思是，狄更斯对你实际上是如何赚钱的完全不感兴趣，但他显然在关注一个至今仍然存在的问题，那就是在某种程度上，圣诞节被塑造成了一种逃离赚钱的
making money, you know, it's sacred and celebration of family and everything and all the things that really matter. But you celebrate it by spending enormous amounts of money. And so that's why people, it seems to me, are always kind of very anxious about the commercialisation of Christmas, even as actually you can't have Christmas without lots of money and spending. No, no, no. The complaints about the commercialisation of Christmas, even as actually you can't have Christmas without lots of money and spending. No, no, no. The complaints about the commercialisation of Christmas, I think, always makes the point that Christmas is by definition a commercial festival. Well, it has been since the emergence of capitalism and industrial society, which again, is the kind of Washington Irving thing. You know, why can't we get back to medieval
日复一日的生活的方式，你知道，它是神圣的，是对家庭和所有真正重要的事情的庆祝。但你庆祝它是通过花巨额金钱来完成的。所以这就是为什么在我看来，人们总是对圣诞节的商业化感到非常焦虑，尽管实际上没有大量的金钱和消费，你就无法过圣诞节。不，不，不。对圣诞节商业化的抱怨，实际上总是指出圣诞节根据定义就是一个商业节日。嗯，自从资本主义和工业社会出现以来就是这样，这又是华盛顿欧文的那种东西。你知道，为什么我们不能回到中世纪的
baronial halls and things? I mean, we can't. No. And if we hadn't, Christmas would be dead. I think that's fair to say that Christmas was only, Christmas reinvented itself as an industrialised urban capitalist festival in which people would buy things and people would buy a lot of food and they would celebrate the kind of the family. Initially, a kind of extended family and increasingly more and more a kind of nuclear family. And more and more a kind of nuclear family.
男爵大厅之类的东西上去呢？我的意思是，我们不能。不。如果我们没有，圣诞节就死掉了。我认为这样说很公平，圣诞节只是，圣诞节把自己重新塑造为一个工业化的城市资本主义节日，在这个节日里，人们会买东西，人们会买大量的食物，他们会庆祝那种家庭。最初，是一种大家庭，越来越多地是一种核心家庭。而且越来越多地是一种核心家庭。
And Dickens played his part in that, but Dickens is often, I mean, the interesting thing, tension with Dickens is that he's simultaneously a very radical writer and also a conservative one. So, you know, his solution is philanthropy, which is a kind of great bulwark of the sort of status quo, isn't it? You make yourself feel better about being a rich capitalist by one day a year buying someone a turkey but i think i think it works actually because it does
狄更斯在其中扮演了他的角色，但狄更斯经常，我的意思是，狄更斯身上有趣的紧张之处在于，他既是一个非常激进的作家，同时又是一个保守的作家。所以，你知道，他的解决方案是慈善事业，这可以说是现状的一大堡垒，不是吗？你一年花一天时间给某人买一只火鸡，就会让自己对作为一个富有的资本主义者感觉好一些，但我认为，我认为它实际上起作用了，因为它确实
go with the grain of the christian story and the way that it's been understood right from the very earliest years and of course the the other one that we talked about at the beginning is this idea that uh you know the angels preach peace um peace on earth, goodwill to men. And that also has generated in the 20th century, a very famous myth. And we've done the First World War, so I know you know everything about the First World War, Dominic. So let's come to... I'm dreading this because I know that First World War buffs are poised, they're poised to write in with complaints about inaccuracies. Yeah, because this is probably the most famous, I guess it's even more famous than the Angel of Mons, isn't it?
符合基督教故事的脉络，以及自最早年代以来人们对它的理解。当然，我们在开始时讨论的另一个是这个想法，呃，你知道，天使宣扬和平，地上和平，人间喜悦。这也引出了20世纪的一个非常著名的神话。我们已经讲过了第一次世界大战，所以我知道你对第一次世界大战无所不知，多米尼克。所以让我们来到……我很害怕这个，因为我知道第一次世界大战的爱好者们已经准备好了，他们准备好写信来抱怨不准确之处了。是的，因为这可能是最著名的，我猜它甚至比蒙斯天使还要著名，对吧？
The idea that the Bowmen of Agincourt appear to marshal the British in the retreat. So this is the Christmas truce, isn't it? Yeah, which is also 9-14, 25th December. The British and Germans come out of their trenches, meet in the middle and supposedly play football. As far as I understand, multiple organised games of football with referees, VAR, penalty shootouts. I've just said that to annoy the war enthusiasts.
阿金库尔的弓箭手出现来引导英国人撤退的想法。所以这就是圣诞停战协定，对吧？是的，这也是9-14年，12月25日。英国人和德国人从战壕里走出来，在中间会合，据传说还踢了足球。据我所知，这是有裁判、VAR、点球大战的组织严密的足球赛。我刚才是为了惹恼战争爱好者才这么说的。
So there's a lot of disagreements among historians about this. There's a historian who gave a presentation recently in the National Archives, and he said there are lots of games of football. And then there are others who say, well, actually, some of the sources are dubious. And, you know, soldiers embellish their accounts later on because they knew they would be rewarded if their stories appeared in the newspapers. So you would be paid if you're, you would get a small fee if your story appeared in the newspaper, and it's better if there's football in it.
所以历史学家对此有很多分歧。有一位历史学家最近在国家档案馆做了一个演讲，他说有很多足球比赛。然后还有其他人说，嗯，实际上，有些消息来源是可疑的。而且，你知道，士兵们后来对他们的叙述进行了润色，因为他们知道如果他们的故事出现在报纸上，他们就会得到报酬。所以如果你的故事出现在报纸上，你会得到报酬，你会得到一小笔费用，如果里面有足球的话就更好了。
But it's clear that there were, let's say there was one, two definite games. Germans against English? I think they were Germans against English, yeah. And I think they're sort of jumpers for goalposts. I mean, obviously, it's very rutted kind of terrain. So I don't think it's a sort of a car a footballing carpet i don't think they're playing ticky tacker man city style kind of short passing game yeah i think it's very much the sort of traditional british long ball um and losing losing on penalties is the traditional joke isn't it
但很明显，有，比方说有一场、两场确定的比赛。德国人对阵英国人？我想他们是德国人对阵英国人，是的。我想他们是用跳投当球门的。我的意思是，很明显，那是那种非常车辙纵横的地形。所以我不认为那是什么足球地毯，我不认为他们踢的是曼城风格的短传配合，是的，我认为这非常类似于传统的英国长传冲吊，嗯，点球落败是传统的笑话，不是吗？
which absolutely we're required to make at this point i I mean, I think there was, you know, it's easy to lose yourself in a bit of a generalisation because in some places there was still fighting. And of course, you know, it wasn't, a lot of the officers were very uneasy about the idea of a truce. Understandably, you know, they want to kill the Germans the next day. They don't like the thought of it.
我们绝对有必要在此时此刻开这个玩笑。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，很容易陷入一些笼统的说法中，因为在某些地方仍然有战斗。当然，你知道，这不是真的，许多军官对停战的想法感到非常不安。可以理解的是，你知道，他们第二天还想杀德国人呢。他们不喜欢这种想法。
Actually, the interesting thing that doesn't often get talked about is on the Eastern Front. So on the Eastern Front, there's a huge siege in a place called Przemysl, which I hope for Polish listeners I've pronounced beautifully. So there's this colossal fortress where the Austro-Hungarians are besieged by the Russians. And of course, it's not Christmas. No, different dates. Different dates. But the Russians, and the Eastern Front is a horrible campaign. You know, there's a lot of ethnic cleansing
实际上，一个不常被谈论的有趣事情是在东线。所以在东线，在一个叫做普热梅斯尔的地方有一场巨大的围城战，希望对于波兰听众来说我这个发音很完美。所以这是一个庞大的要塞，奥匈帝国军队被俄国人围困。当然，这不是圣诞节。不，不同的日期。不同的日期。但是俄国人，东线是一场可怕的战役。你知道，有很多种族清洗
and there's a lot of sort of bitterness and bad blood. This is in the First World War. It's in the First World War. Yeah. And the Russian besiegers leave cards and indeed presents of sausages and things for the Austrian patrols to find outside the walls of the city and they say you know we know this is Christmas for you um so we've left you a few
还有很多痛苦和不和。这是在第一次世界大战中。这是在第一次世界大战中。是的。俄国包围者留下卡片，甚至还有香肠之类的礼物，让奥地利巡逻队在城市城墙外找到，他们说，你知道，我们知道这对你们来说是圣诞节，嗯，所以我们给你们留下了一些
nice treats and whatnot and you know we look forward to besieging you again tomorrow that is a lovely that is a lovely note on I think on which to end I can't see how we could top that. That is a truly festive note. Yeah. The thought of starting the bombardment again on Boxing Day. Well, yes. You know, we'll have Christmas and then we'll be back to Tier 3. Anyway, Dominic, you know, happy Christmas. Happy Christmas to all the, to everyone who's listening to this.
不错的零食之类东西，你知道，我们期待明天再次围攻你们。这是一个可爱的，这是一个很好的结尾，我想我想不出我们怎么能超越这个。这真的是一个有节日气氛的便条。是的。一想到节礼日又要开始轰炸了。好吧，是的。你知道，我们要过圣诞节，然后我们要回到第三级。无论如何，多米尼克，你知道，圣诞快乐。祝所有人，祝所有听这个节目的人圣诞快乐。
And we will speak to you again i hope in the new year by humbug thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望能在新年再次与您对话。唉，废话。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。这就是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。